[Music]
welcome back to hot seat this is the
show on youtube with the hottest seat
and and we're we got david so here today
pretty hot
that's why that's how we introduce the
[ __ ]
hey welcome back to hot seat the show
with the hottest here on youtube
because
we asked them inflaming questions that's
what it is
take it
we first start off cold yes all right
cool questions and then we come
winter is coming we boil it slowly and
then we [ __ ] turn up the heat on you
so david first question how much do you
love your grandmother
before after she died
before
she answered both all right all right
would you love her more after she died
the best
here's another question how did you get
on youtube how did you what was your
first youtube video how did you start uh
first youtube video ever was a
mockumentary series of me making fun of
my everyday life because i hated my life
really
online it's still up there and i did it
with a cheap little sony xd cam and i
did it with my best friend at the time i
was in college
and i was also working two part-time
jobs i stopped doing stand-up so i
switched over to doing youtube because i
used to watch this guy named shane
dawson and i saw his stuff and i was
like dude this guy not funny and so i
decided
i decided to do my own thing
i thought i was going the other
direction i thought it was going to be
misdirection this inspires me
and i didn't i didn't know that he was
doing comedy that's the most korean [ __ ]
i've ever heard
[ __ ] that guy i could do it better and
so i saw this stuff and i was like oh
because i thought youtube at the time
was only a place where you needed like a
special account to upload videos because
i just watched it to like fix my car or
do some other [ __ ] or watch like korean
dramas and [ __ ] like that so i didn't
know that you could create your own
content and so when i stopped doing
stand-up i switched over to making
youtube content where i would just do
funny sketches just just for fun just to
see if i could do it then i went into
these like random like late night rants
where i'll just start talking [ __ ] and
then the rest is history what was the
most popular rant that you did uh the
one with the uh the white girl who said
asians are loud which was true asians in
the library yeah in retrospect big facts
very very true what's something that
drives you crazy about yourself
i can't control my eating
yeah that would be up there
i can't i can't control it it's so
[ __ ] obnoxious
i second that dude i remember i spent
the whole weekend with you in sacramento
and just realizing that we were never
hungry
dude shows up to lunch today
with more lunch
for all of us i never had a break i felt
like we ate breakfast and the breakfast
was all the way up until dinner and then
my mom in the middle will be like you
fat [ __ ] and then she brings more food
she woke this dude up just to smack him
in the face and call him fast oh my god
that's my mom did all right if you could
fight any youtuber who would you fight
and for free or for money or what uh for
money anything you're your dream
scenario fight because i never i never
want to fight somebody that's not good
because it makes you look stupid right
it's like nobody would ever respect you
just like a bully immediately what the
[ __ ] you talking about
i have a good point though you could
just do that regularly anyways right but
it's lethargic though like people want
to see you beat someone up because they
don't like that person dana white comes
to you
mma boxing whatever fight you want i'll
set it up i'll make it where you get
paid
10 million that brother person gets 10
million who the [ __ ] do you want to
fight who is somebody my size it's a
jake paul that was that's also fat why
do they gotta be fast because we want to
make it even gabriel glaciers he should
fight gabriel well i'll [ __ ] i love
him but i'll fight him he's big big
though yeah i know he's big bear i met
him he's not even that baby's not that
fat
didn't gabriel lose some weight recently
like gabriel probably got 100 pounds on
david yeah but not like you know the
pounds that that you like to help win
fights
you know like no disrespect to him so
who's the big youtuber then that's hard
to say
we don't we don't really watch youtube
what about like so it's hard for us to
really be like brothers or something or
anything like that
would there be brothers i would fight
one of the fine brothers dude
i would not i would take on the not hot
one what about the worth it guys would
you [ __ ] those guys was it worth it guys
you know the guys oh the worth it guys
we have one of them here i know they're
great i love them [ __ ] steve
steven lim oh yeah steve
he created that uh ten dollar burger
versus a thousand dollar verb
he's too frail and kind though like
nobody wants to see him fight yeah you
don't want to bully someone yeah you
don't want to see a guy shatter his
wrists during a punch
the shatter is a round of applause
he just does this and there's an x-ray
all the bows are shattered
yeah go on come on dust like that old
school ntv claymation wrestling match
he's the kind of guy that you want to
protect the damsel in distress
he's the kind of guy who you knock out
and then you grab the mic and you go it
was worth it
[Laughter]
he's on fire bro
i wonder i really wonder i don't i don't
i have to watch more youtube to figure
out
who i was sam i don't know youtube
anymore that's what i can only do old
references
i don't even watch tick tocks i'm gonna
turn up the heat a little bit out of all
the asian american entertainers
or or movie whatever celebrities who do
you think you can just you know kind of
flick off the table you don't really
care that they're part of the
oh that's easy dude my favorite people
ever my best friends the fang bros dude
they challenge the asian agenda love it
every day remember steve yeah please
whatever race you are that's why you're
a loser
[Laughter]
the reason why you can't get women is
because you're asian dude and i'm trying
to change that oh bro all asian men have
ever got women before that's sick and
the reason why
because they're gooks
you flick both of them
i said you only need like one of them oh
both you know what i actually like those
guys they make me laugh super hard
really why is why is [ __ ] a white
chick like the top of the castle or like
the big final i don't know
[Laughter]
they're like dude i feel like dude i
play super mario my whole life and i
have to get my princess peach yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] that's what it is
every asian guy is trying to get their
princess peach yeah you know yeah but
then you know i think they're they're
nice dudes so what's the whole point
yeah i mean it's not it's more like
roasting them instead of violence
against them yeah and i'm also like
twice their size and i think they're
really nice guys like i just dislike
their content yeah yeah i just like
their creative voice
and their messaging yeah yeah yeah you
know but like you know i'd go to their
house and eat their food
i don't like hanging out
yeah yeah they don't muck bang with them
you know that's how it is knowing most
youtubers though yeah like you mean
there's like i don't really [ __ ] with
you but i need a sandwich with you
i don't want to watch you but you're
kind of nice yeah
uh okay what do you think about what's
what's your thoughts on
uh
shane
we know
i have three podcasts about it
just for people who can't listen to the
whole thing oh it's it's one
it's a bad film it was not good
let's talk about that i love how much of
sugar coated that's awesome yeah if you
if you want to know the reasons why you
can watch my podcast and i break it down
for like an hour and a half do you feel
pressured from the asian community to
[ __ ] like just love everything that
comes out all right i feel like no
pressure at all suck my [ __ ]
if i don't like it i don't have to
[ __ ] like it just because you look
like me [ __ ] and by the way i look like
everybody's asian baby anyway so what
the [ __ ] happened but think about what
you're doing to the movement right now
david i know david what the [ __ ] moving
my nutsacks in your mouth [ __ ] how
about that
how about that the best part is like
this these movies everyone's talking
about how much they crushed it how much
money they made and the idea that you
can take that money away from them is
like [ __ ] absurd
you single-handedly can take down disney
they still got great paychecks that's
what we can by the way when we do a
movie review it doesn't mean that you
can't like the [ __ ] film do your own
movie review and tell me how much you
love it and then we can discuss it i
don't give a [ __ ] if you like it
there are people who love andrew
garfield spider-man whereas most of us
know that it was ass garfunkel dude this
guy loves it dude attacker should do a
review channel because he loves that one
his favorite spider-man there are people
who go to amy schumer [ __ ] stand-up
comedy and they cry laughing dude no
they get carried out of their own
stretchers
because they also had heart attacks
dude they [ __ ] died laughing
i'm gonna turn it down way cold okay out
of all the asian hate crime videos which
one was the funniest one to use
that's a good question
the funniest asian hate crime video that
has ever happened was when i got
attacked outside my gym
that's crazy outside of my gym you're
[ __ ] huge someone tried to what the
[ __ ] so i was in south pacific this is
like the funniest thing ever so i'm in
south pasadena go train at the gym and
there's this guy so south where we're
out in south pass is right next to
highland park so there's a bunch of
[ __ ] like druggies and [ __ ] out there
in the metro station too yes and so i'm
talking about
this guy literally like classic
early 19
like 1980s movie shoulder bumps me like
in like the hallway type of thing
and he hits me in the shoulder i'm like
hey what the [ __ ] and he goes what's up
you know typically what happens when
somebody approaches me if anybody wants
to fight i run away like there's no
point i won't fight anybody like what's
the what's if you can walk away just
[ __ ] walk away [ __ ] right here
yeah [ __ ] right bro
i will knock you the [ __ ] out stab
somebody in the face with a pencil
my mom that was talking too
keep that same energy
today's video is brought to you by babel
man learning new languages oh why is it
so difficult and why has it got to be so
boring
man i wish there was a program out there
that would help me
thanks to babel there is because they
are the number one selling language app
out there you can check them out it is
so nice and what's dope about their
lesson plans they don't follow some
traditional textbook they got a
i
where it helps you learn it's
intelligent learning and you get to
learn stuff created by a hundred
language experts yeah and these lessons
they're only like 15 minutes so you
don't have to be in a classroom for like
two hours you don't have to look at a
book or a textbook you don't even know
if it's pronounced right or whatever but
that's the pretty awesome thing is
because they got the voice recognition
technology where you can speak it into
into the app and they're like yeah
that's right that's right or not and one
of my favorite parts is they also have a
20-day money-back guarantee meaning if
you're trying to learn another language
and you're like let's see if this is for
me you could try it out for two weeks
and you're like you know what it hasn't
been working and they'll give you a full
refund so if you want to learn another
language i would definitely check out
babel because right now they got a
special deal too go to babel.com and for
a three-month subscription you get
another three months for free that's six
months for the price of three all you
have to do is go to
babel.combabbel.com and use the promo
code off the record the promo code is
off the record at babel.com
learn another language see you next time
he's so he shoulder bumps me i turn
around i go what the [ __ ] i didn't like
direct any anger towards him i was just
like what the [ __ ] i walk around this
guy goes what's up doesn't give me any
chest just swings at me oh straight up
swings at me and so i literally tried to
like stuff the shot but then what
happened i don't know what hit either
his chin or his head but he knocked i
had a black eye for like a couple of
weeks because he he actually hit you or
i think it was like his chin or his head
or his shoulder or something because i
kind of tried to stuff the shot yeah and
at this point what's stuff in the chat i
know [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ] it's just if
somebody does an overhand at you if you
stuff the shot you kind of break the
range of motion what does that look like
you get close you get close you want to
go like this so if you do like like
overhand over hand like that
oh that stuff this is not oh i just
stuffed it and then he could do that
quickly like in the moment i guess but
all the training i've been trying for
three years
[Laughter]
david was wrong
he was wrong
i've been on
youtube also dude i also got a black eye
for this so obviously it didn't work
whatever it was i had like a and so when
you get hit out of nowhere the first
thing you see you know the cartoon when
you see stars this whole eye fuzzy it's
just like a thing you just see like
you're right when your tv is fuzzy so
it's just like ringing and [ __ ]
and three years of boxing and kickboxing
it is my time to [ __ ] this guy up yes
i'll tell you what i did i use none of
it
i [ __ ] grab him with my left hand and
i just push him against this half brick
wall i smash him onto the wall like a
serial killer no anger i just started
slapping him just wow
wow
wow and i had this windbreaker on
so he couldn't grab me
so i just kept slapping him full [ __ ]
force and let me tell you something that
[ __ ] hurts your [ __ ] hand my hand was
throbbing
her actually hurts so bad but it's
better than uh full fist because you're
gonna hurt your hand i dislocated my
hand punching a dude that's what i'm
saying but i'm not even thinking i'm
just going back to the first martial
arts i know where my parents used to be
i just start slapping this dude and then
i grab him by his [ __ ] pants and his
shirt and i throw him out like jazzy
jeff from fresh prince and i just
chucked his ass and he gets up he's like
[ __ ] you i'll [ __ ] kill you i think
he's [ __ ] crazy
but that's basically what happened
that's crazy dude
he just ran away after that just ran
away and i slapped him [ __ ] hella
hard that was david so it's funniest
asian hate moment
where is this video and how can we watch
this yeah
there's no cameras outside the gym i
[ __ ] wish we've hit the 13
minute mark which is when we like to get
real personal on a real real
now it gets really steaming from my mind
now we're going to ask you a real
personal question the woo hon
water baby
should have known better and that
personal question is
what
is you're 30 something now you've been
for some time right what is one of your
biggest regrets in your 20s uh i wish i
would have lost weight earlier do you
think
weight battling is like a huge deal in
your life i think i've always had like
uh there's a lot of things i wish i
would have done earlier like for example
i wish i would have started like
taking kickboxing and boxing a lot
earlier because then i probably would
have taken it a lot further but there's
always a give and take right you can't
[ __ ] kick box and box three hours a
day and then run a business i don't
think that's possible
and so not at the level that in a pro
level no not at the level if you want to
get better there's a certain point that
i realized that you can get up to here
doing it casually and the rest is time
now it's just it's just road work it's
grind and i don't care enough about it
to do that part for me to forego
everything else so i wish i would have
done it when i had more time but that's
probably the only semi regret i have but
i don't like and then the weight thing
as a as that would have came hand in
hand with it right because athletics all
that because i [ __ ] up my knees like
my knees are all [ __ ] up my back's all
[ __ ] up and that's just from me not
working out and just not caring about my
health and that's like time you don't
give back
you know mariel would have been happier
too you're one of the most athletic fat
dudes that i know yeah you are that's a
good compliment backhanded compliment
where do you think that comes from no i
mean like not not i mean you're not fat
now but when you were like when we go
[ __ ] play basketball for seven hours
straight dude i'm like how is this fat
dude keeping up with us he's like
drinking milk on the sidelines
i just [ __ ] take a little speed
i'm so surprised he's not fainting and
we need to [ __ ] put a donut in his
mouth to wake him up and [ __ ] you know
he's just going
dude we used to play basketball for like
five hours straight somebody get him a
donut we're like what you need to wake
up nah dude what do you think it is your
relationship with food like is it a
comfort thing
it just tastes good
it just tastes good like me and david
got the same approach on food where if
we're sad we'll eat if we're happy we're
gonna eat too yeah so you just no matter
what it's just like a celebratory thing
or it's a coping thing whatever foods
you saw you know what happened what
really [ __ ] me up is when i started
making money because now my options just
blew the [ __ ] up it's like so budgeting
and being broke made you less fat
because you couldn't eat so much it's
also like the poverty mentality too
when i eat food and there's stuff that's
expensive even if i'm full you're more
going oh me too yeah because that right
there was 36.42 yep you know and i'm
like i'm going to eat that when i was
younger i couldn't eat that food so i'm
gonna [ __ ] eat it and if you leave
that leftover guess what i don't take
leftovers dude i eat everything on the
[ __ ] table dude i took a leftover i
mean nick you were staying at the bike
the other night the bicycle
and uh i was full already because this
chick was playing poker the whole time
you don't take that
and i got like a [ __ ] i got like another
meal to eat with her because it's her
birthday and [ __ ] and then
they're like
do you want to
take it with you and i was like yeah and
then i knew the whole time i wasn't
going to eat it yeah i literally just
walked it back in the room put in the
fridge and then i left without even
getting it you know i just know i'm a
piece of [ __ ] like that i'll never
i'll never do it it's just hard like
when you have like for example when you
know when i was in vegas and i had like
the whole food treatment i didn't have
to eat eight skewers
but that was a5
you're gonna eat it you didn't pay for
you got the whole thing for [ __ ]
sponsor if i did pay for it you would
know how much that cost if you had to
pay for it how much more would you have
eaten do you think i would have ate way
more how much how much did it cost how
about that uh the whole i think the
whole experience was four hundred
dollars jesus yeah so it's per person so
800 bucks for two people i don't even
spend 400 when i get groceries yeah no
yeah for a month yeah that's like oh
yeah well you're not single but you're
also not buying caviar [ __ ] yeah yeah
there was a5 wagyu there was a sturgeon
caviar there was gold flakes on stuff
unnecessary and that buy gold flakes
from albuquerque
yeah why why did they do that i don't
know it doesn't taste like anything it's
a presentation presentation thing i
don't want to eat gold though i want to
melt it and wear it
they'll have like gold flake corn dogs
which is so stupid it's like it's a
[ __ ] corn dog i know i want to chip
off the flakes and then
keep it you know make a ring out of it
or something i just love food food is
[ __ ] fire dude and there's no you
have no like uh coping mechanism with
food at all like stereotypically they
say that i don't
the way that i eat when i'm stressed is
the way i eat when i'm happy yeah so
you're just non-stop i just want to try
new things and like for example tooth
like just yesterday i made a pumpkin pie
for no [ __ ] god reason you didn't
bring anything yeah you're so weird like
that dude pumpkin pie is bomb how did it
have it come out oh it came out great
it's like there's like a fun experiment
thing too that i'm trying it out with so
well we got a bunch of free pumpkins
from trader joe's just because it was
free
because they
they ordered too much sugar pumpkins and
they couldn't sell them so they had them
in a cart for free so a buddy i brought
like four pumpkins over and i was like
gotta make pumpkin pie i didn't know for
the longest time that pumpkin pie was
actually made out of pumpkins like
predominantly made out of pumpkins
i just didn't i just didn't think it was
even real because yeah the way the
pumpkins smell i'm like this is
something good for this [ __ ]
cinnamon in that all right i'll end the
video with this and we have a little bit
of time left uh not that many people
know that you actually have a brother
growing up what was the biggest fight
that you've had with him this fool put
me in a crippler crossface
what's that and it hurts
so bad
i told you i get my ass beat all the
time oh so so they would basically trap
one of your arms and then he wrapped his
hands around my forehead and he yanked
oh how old are you and how was his size
i was i think this is just before i
outgrew him so i was probably seven and
then he was like
he was like dead
crippler cross faced me and he didn't
realize how much it hurt and i was
screaming so it's like a reverse can
opener so he just [ __ ] starts
snapping my spine back and i was
screaming and he just didn't know how
much it hurt and then his friend did it
to me after again
because it was funny because it was
funny to them did you end up like
wailing on them or like
this is when i was still really small
but in korean culture too you never wail
on somebody who's older than you there's
like a mental block of them beating your
ass when you're so young you just can't
put your hands on them yeah
i put my hands on him once and then we
never i never did it again did you feel
so bad after oh i felt terrible you
betrayed your people
i felt i felt bad because his feelings
were hurt i see because his younger
brother actually hit him you know yeah
but then he had it [ __ ] coming that
[ __ ] like this dude
he didn't understand the concept at the
time that i think i was getting older
and i was you know starting to have my
own opinions and thoughts so it wasn't
that your thoughts were law and even
when i was a kid i was just like you
could have your opinion i could have my
opinion two things can be true at once
just [ __ ] just do your own thing and
it was i still remember the argument or
what it was not what it was about but
what we were arguing about was
i basically had an opinion about
something i had a different opinion i
said hey you just think what you think
i'll think what i think and he goes no
you're wrong and i'm like
it's okay just do what you do and i'll
do what i do just leave me alone he goes
no say that i'm right and i'm like
you need to leave me by the way i'm
twice the size of this point and then he
comes up
slaps me upside my head what's the
[ __ ] force i do the same thing i
[ __ ] pick him up and i slam him
upside down on his head into the couch i
don't think that's the same thing
i did the same thing
i mean the same thing as uh the guy at
the the gym where i chucked them so i
basically picked them up
and i dipped them and i slammed them and
then like jersey joe
and then he gets up and he's so shocked
he just looks at me like disappointed
and he gets up and he walks out
and then my mom looks at me and she goes
you [ __ ] up
i look at my mom was like he hit me and
she goes yeah but you don't hit your
older brother oh [ __ ]
so this is those moments when you're a
kid where everything is so confusing you
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
rules are [ __ ] i don't understand
what you mean he hit me uh why can't i
do something is like my mom said you
hurt his feelings
[Laughter]
he literally slapped me upside my head
so i would just piss you the favorite
like the oh they loved him dude
oh
i one time just this quick story
we got into this one fight this dude
literally comes up and he loves slapping
me upside my head and i love he's such a
gentle guy now i see him aggressively
for real
and he's so quiet calmest man ever some
[ __ ] happened but he slept he slapped me
upside my head and it's like a korean
thing to do is to slap people inside
their head it's like i don't know why
but he does that [ __ ] and i turn around
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i move my
chair like a rolly chair and i push his
back and i don't do that and i guess he
sprained his thumb in basketball earlier
that morning and i pushed it back and
then he socks me in my head
and then i turn around and then he
punches me in the eye
[ __ ] gives me a black eye i sh i
shove him he we break the tv
right
i come outside my eye is shut he full on
decks me in the eye i look at my mom and
she goes what did you do to your brother
[Laughter]
you have a swollen hand check this [ __ ]
out sucks me in the eye i have a black
eye my mom starts beating the [ __ ] out
of me because i pushed my brother and i
broke the tv jesus right then my dad
comes home he goes what did you do to
your brother oh no beats my ass simply
because i broke the hierarchy of
speaking to somebody older to you like
that like you're not supposed to do not
for breaking the tv my dad would kick my
ass
so i got my ass beat by all the family
members
it was it was great holy [ __ ] yeah what
kind of tv was it it was one of those
old ass tube tvs you know back in the
day this year yeah
yeah so expensive as [ __ ] basically yeah
i don't need therapy at all no you're
good you're good bro you're way good
your relationship with food is just
because you like food
[Laughter]
it's delicious
[Music]
you